joining us is someone that i just cannot
wait to have a conversation at just27
she not only hosts the fifth
most stream podcast
in the whole world but she also made
headlines with her reported 60 million
dollar spotify deal the biggest
exclusive deal ever for a woman-led
podcast
here to break those blast feelings
is the woman behind call her daddy alex
cooper
now
i was interested um because i thought oh
call her daddy i wasn't exactly sure
like how i was supposed to take the name
but tell me if i understand it correctly
that by daddy it means that a woman can
do whatever a man can do absolutely okay
father cooper father cooper what i love
is watching you
grow and evolve so quickly like
just even within a few years you're also
like pitching therapy and talking about
mental wellness and growing yourself and
taking people along for that journey so
which part
like if any would you change or do you
love the whole narrative because it's
the building blocks of who you are who
you're becoming and then some
definitely wouldn't change a thing i am
so proud of the evolution of call her
daddy i wanted to make it a normal
conversation everyone wants to talk
about sex and dating and mental health
but for some reason it's hard to do it
publicly and so i just figured let's
take my education public and let me
speak on my experiences and hopefully me
being vulnerable and honest
will make others feel less alone and
more inclined to lean into
self-acceptance
where do you think that you got your
confidence because you do have a lot of
confidence and i love it thank you
it was
not my whole life like i
i think it's important especially with
the age of social media like everything
seems perfect everyone's life is perfect
i'm sure everyone's looking up at me
here and like oh like the suit is cute
and she's got it going on she got the
deal when i was younger
if you passed me on a street you would
be like oh my god that girl needs
accutane like i had the skin that was
it was awful it was debilitating and i
also struggled with weight which i know
it's been hard for me to discuss because
i know it's like oh woe is you but i was
so thin that i was called like
malnourished etc and i would
i actually never talked about this
i would layer three leggings tape them
to my legs and then put on my school
pants because i was bullied by the guys
of like how i didn't have a butt or i
was too thin and so
there was a lot during my adolescent
years that i
was at my lowest i was not confident and
i felt so confident on the soccer field
or with my girlfriend that's right
you're a huge soccer player yes which
must have bred tremendous amount of
discipline like you are serious yeah you
know it was a career absolutely and but
i always felt like it was interesting
being in a locker room with women my
whole life i would also recognize there
was a divide between the women that felt
comfortable just openly talking about
sex dating whatever it was or the women
that maybe weren't as inclined to open
up but it wasn't because they didn't
want to it was because they maybe looked
at those topics as taboo because of
their upbringing and so i think when i
got out of college i was just like i
thought someone's got to talk about this
like let's get into it and i think
that's where call her daddy originated
of me being like i'm gonna open the
conversation and i know podcasts are
always like we're unfiltered and we're
raw like no call her daddy takes it
there like the goal after you listen to
a call her daddy episode is to leave
feeling so
good about yourself but also
inspired to do better for yourself now
your mom is here by the way i can't help
but say hello to laurie hi lloyd
ask lori
what do you want for your daughter in
you know this time of life well i so far
i think she's doing a really great job
i'm very proud of her and i i just
really honestly she's just just saying
the uh the message of i'd like her to
just continue to use the platform to
support and encourage people i mean
that's that's my background and
profession and that's what i wanted to
do yeah she's a psychologist well may
you continue to rise in your platform
and go all the way with that and i just
i i am loving it and by the way i'm
dying to know who mr zoom is you've
managed to keep your relationship like
everybody knows everything about your
personal life how have you kept your
boyfriend a secret i i really
love the privacy i've done the public
thing i think again it goes back to like
the age of social media we feel like we
have to show everything i would just
encourage anyone like look at yourself
even aside from relationships i always
like to ask myself would i be doing this
if i couldn't post it on instagram like
are you going there just to get the
instagram photo for the grammar no but
don't do it for me
because it's fully consuming our lives
then i think for me and i've taken this
new journey of i think every single
photo that's edited should have to have
a sign somewhere saying
edited like i
opened up recently about getting caught
photo shopping i was feeling
really insecure about my body it was my
birthday i was having fun in las vegas
oh there it is thanks guys um and i had
i had an insecure moment and i cinched
in my waist and when i got called out
for it which i love that is my
relationship with my listeners is they i
hold them accountable they hold me
accountable in that moment i was like
wait why did i do that
maybe if i with my platform openly say
i'm done every photo you now see of me
going forward i will not photoshop that
will inspire others to be a little bit
more authentic because again it's like
who are we doing this for i completely
agree thank you so
[Applause]
with new much airing every wednesday
night
[Music]